Danica Patrick is going to have some new
competition
uber announced on Tuesday and is
creating 1 million jobs for women by
2020 according to Nashville the
initiative is the result of a
partnership with un women a United
Nations organization committed to global
gender equality a mission that can only
be accomplished when all women have
direct access to safe and equitable
earning opportunities alright more women
who bird drivers that seems good to me I
personally don't care whether my uber
driver is a man or a woman or something
in between or from another planet
doesn't really matter as long as they
get me to where I'm going but I do think
it's sort of interesting as women do you
guys feel when you hop in an uber do you
feel safer if it's a woman driver I mean
most of my uber drivers have been women
really yes that's kind of like I've been
listening to this story and I was like
what is that not already happening
that's interesting I think maybe la our
sense of what's going on with Ruben and
the bigger thing is being skewed I and I
do feel like every time I get in the car
and it's a woman I'm like a little bit
relieved because I've had some creepy
experiences with dudes and it's just
like I like to not have to worry about
that yeah what about you I honestly
don't think about it either way for some
reason I swear living in New York and
taking endless amounts of taxicabs has
built up this false sense of I will
never get in an accident in this car it
doesn't matter how bad they're driving
I'm not gonna wear my seat belt even
though I were everywhere in every other
car right I don't know why that is
that's interesting though so you took it
to a place of like some idea of like
maybe women or worse drivers but I think
most people fear it more that if a woman
gets in the car that the man is like a
pervert yeah you're not you're
definitely not worried yeah so you but
you meant it more for like is this guy
like a weirdo not necessarily that guys
might be better driver I don't
yeah the driving is hopefully they all
can drive since there were drivers yeah
but ya know I've just had some kind of
creepy guys if I'm like with a group of
friends it doesn't matter yeah if I'm
going somewhere on my own I'd rather it
be a girl driving but I mean it's it is
what it is yeah to your point about the
taxi drivers like sometimes I get in an
uber and it's so pleasant and it smells
nice and I was in one last night and the
guy had all these lollipops and it told
me of water and all this stuff and
chocolate
and then every now and again I don't
think boy I do miss like an
old-fashioned New York City dirty gross
smelly gaudy sweat like like you was
having to lay a plastic bag over your
potentially drive on like puke over
there like some other bodily fluid like
there's something like about it that I
kind of miss is that totally happy
that's really like a lollipop it's just
it's like stepping into a magical fairy
land I'm like what do you have chocolate
I don't normally even eat this stuff but
I love you a lollipop it was the last
time I literally had candy candy bar
wasn't and over because he had a whole
barrel of like an actual barrel of candy
I'm like I want to like throw it off by
itself but then you gave him five stars
than you were whatever the match started
yeah really be horrible for me to give
us the five cents yeah you know I got a
new bird pick me up once and the guy
said to me that he almost didn't pick me
up because I didn't have as a user I
didn't have like the Mac stars what did
I do what I don't know what I cuz
usually I'm pretty quiet like I don't
talk that much in them yeah outside
waiting I try I try to I try to be final
thought on this what do you think for
the people that I know that some people
are gonna watch this and say well men
are just better drivers that's just how
it is men are better drivers women are
nervous behind the wheel
Burke murdered gunner say something to
those people I mean I'm a good driver
hey no no I mean that's a that's a silly
stereotype that's it yeah well I mean
the fact is I mean woman's insurance
rates are lower for a reason you know I
would like to just throw in the fact
that this is an incredibly smart move
for uber because they're aiming
everyone they're partnering with the UN
like what they're taking right sure and
then taking over the world
I'm so confused but you know there are
eight ways to have 1 million female
drivers in the next you know couple
years whatever that's and and they're
saying that currently it's 14% of their
drivers or women so that means they're
basically aiming to have 8 million plus
drivers total in a couple years they're
just going to take over the roads I mean
this is a really smart Avenue approach
to take I think normally we don't do
math on the show but that I just did all
that math in my head a lot of math
anyway
do you like lollipops let us know in the
comments right now